Grazie a tutti
Buonasera a tutti
Il cimitero del Perlachaise è uno dei luoghi più visitati di Parigi
Fa tre milioni e mezzo di visitatori ogni anno
Lì sono sepolti Jim Morrison, Edith Piaf, Oscar Wilde, Marcel Proust, Modigliani
In un angolo del muro di cinta del Perlachaise c'è una lapide
Che in francese dice ai morti della comune
21-28 maggio 1871
E sotto non mancano mai i fiori
Contro quel muro in quell'angolo
Il 27 maggio del 1871
L'esercito francese fucilò 147 fra uomini e donne
E li seppellì in una fossa comune
Nei giorni seguenti vennero ammucchiati nella stessa fossa altre centinaia di cadaveri
Di gente fucilata altrove e poi sepolta lì
Oppure portata lì viva per essere fucilata
Il cimitero del Perlachaise non è in centro a Parigi
È in periferia, è adiacente al quartiere operaio di
Quello che una volta era il quartiere operaio di Belleville
Quello dove sono ambientati i romanzi di Pennac
Avete presente? Ecco
E i fucilati di quei giorni erano gli operai del quartiere e le loro donne
Che avevano difeso le ultime barricate contro l'esercito del governo
Che stava riconquistando Parigi
Parigi che si era ribellata e aveva rifiutato di riconoscere l'autorità del governo
È l'ultimo giorno di quella che è passata la storia come la settimana di sangue
Nessuno sa quanta gente sia stata ammazzata in quella settimana per le strade di Parigi
Perché, come dire, questa storia è una storia così carica dal punto di vista ideologico
Che non c'è nessuno che sia riuscito a studiarla senza avere, come dire, un qualche pregiudizio
Nessuno storico è mai riuscito a essere del tutto imparziale
C'è sempre la tentazione di sminuire il cumulo dei morti
Oppure di esagerarlo
Detto questo, non c'è nessuno che scenda sotto gli 8.000-10.000 morti
Ammazzati per le strade di Parigi in una settimana
E con quei 8.000-10.000 morti venne soffocata nel sangue
Quella che quasi nessuno oggi chiama la guerra civile francese
A voi magari sarà sembrata anche strana questa definizione
Non siamo abituati a pensare a una guerra civile francese
Forse perché è stata troppo breve
Due mesi
E la conclusione una settimana appunto
Però Karl Marx
Che in quelle settimane pubblicò
Prima ancora che finisse
Pubblicò un libro
Per documentare appunto la violenza di questa repressione
Lo intitolò la guerra civile in Francia
Noi oggi parliamo piuttosto della comune di Parigi
Ecco questo è il modo di entrare in argomento
Quando nel fondo si simpatizza per i ribelli di Parigi
E quando il sentimento dominante è l'orrore
Per quelle migliaia di uomini e donne
Fucilati per le strade
Però c'è anche naturalmente giustamente
C'è anche chi di fronte a queste stesse vicende
Se dovesse dire la cosa che gli fa più orrore
Magari ne citerebbe un'altra
Tutto il contrario
Dovete sapere che fin dai primi combattimenti
Fra i ribelli di Parigi e l'esercito del governo
E quindi due mesi prima della settimana di sangue
Quando fin dai primi giorni di combattimenti
Si capisce che i governativi
Fucilano i prigionieri
La comune
Cioè il governo della Parigi insorta
La comune emana un decreto sugli ostaggi
In cui si stabilisce che vengano arrestate
Tutte le persone sospettate di complicità con il nemico
E quelli che saranno giudicati colpevoli
Verranno trattenuti in ostaggio
E se i soldati del governo continueranno a fucilare
Allora noi fucileremo gli ostaggi
Il decreto all'inizio viene applicato solo a metà
Nel senso che si fanno gli arresti
Si arrestano decine di ostaggi
In particolare preti e frati
Viene arrestato anche l'arcivescovo di Parigi
Monsignor Darbois
Tenete conto che siamo nell'Ottocento
E nell'Ottocento tutti i movimenti rivoluzionari
Sono violentemente anticlericali
Perché vedono nella Chiesa
Un nemico ostinato del progresso
Della democrazia
E va anche detto che trattandosi della Chiesa del 1870
Non hanno torto
La Chiesa del 1870
La Chiesa di Pio IX
È una Chiesa ferocemente reazionaria
E chiusa a qualunque novità
Sta di fatto che i rivoluzionari di Parigi
Sono violentemente anticlericali
Arrestano l'arcivescovo
Preti, frati
Per un bel po' però non fucilano nessuno
Anche se i governativi continuano a fucilare prigionieri
Per molto tempo
Per settimane e settimane
Gli ostaggi non vengono toccati
E poi comincia la settimana di sangue
21-28 maggio
Quando cioè dopo un mese e mezzo di combattimenti in periferia
L'esercito dà l'assalto al centro di Parigi
E a ogni barricata
A ogni strada conquistata
I soldati mettono al muro i prigionieri
E li fucilano
Allora
Allora il capo della polizia della comune
Che è un rivoluzionario giovanissimo
È uno studente
Di famiglia borghese
Si chiama Raul Rigaud
È un rivoluzionario fanatico
Fautore del terrore contro i nemici del popolo
Fautore anche della libertà sessuale peraltro
Raul Rigaud fa trasferire a questo punto
Negli ultimi giorni in cui la rivoluzione di Parigi
Viene soffocata nel sangue
Raul Rigaud capo della polizia della comune
Fa trasferire gli ostaggi
Dalle varie prigioni in cui si trovavano
Alla prigione della Roquette
Che è la prigione dei condannati a morte
Fuori dalla prigione
Mentre si spara e si ammazza in tutta Parigi
La folla reclama la fucilazione degli ostaggi
E allora entra in scena un'altra autorità della comune
Il presidente del tribunale rivoluzionario
Theophile Ferret
Anche lui è un giovanissimo
Questi ragazzi hanno 25 anni
26 anni
D'accordo?
Fanno impressione
Anche se devo dire che nelle foto dell'epoca
Sembrano molto più vecchi
Con le barbe, il panciotto, gli occhialini
Si invecchiava in fretta nell'ottocento
Ma erano ragazzi di 25 anni
Theophile Ferret sotto la pressione della folla
Dà l'ordine
Quegli altri stanno continuando a fucilare
Perciò fuciliamo anche noi
E quindi sei ostaggi sono messi al muro
E fucilati
Fra loro l'arcivescovo di Parigi
È un episodio che suscita orrore in tutto il mondo
E anche oggi
Chi rievoca la comune di Parigi
Non è detto che per prima cosa pensi
Alle migliaia di operaie di donne
Fucilati per le strade
Molti pensano per prima cosa
All'arcivescovo di Parigi
Messo al muro e fucilato
C'è chi pensa che fucilare un arcivescovo
Sia molto più grave
Che non fucilare dei poveracci per la strada
Ognuno su questo può pensare quello che vuole
Naturalmente
Due anni dopo la fine della guerra civile
Nel 1873
Lo stato francese decide
Che sulla collina di Montmartre
Che oggi è da molto tempo
È un posto di locali notturni e di turisti
Ma che allora era un quartiere operaio
Era l'altro quartiere operaio
Che insieme a Belleville
Era stato al centro della resistenza
Il governo decide
Che sulla collina di Montmartre
Bisogna costruire un'immensa basilica
Per espiare
Così si dice
I crimini dei rivoluzionari
Primo fra tutti
La fucilazione dell'arcivescovo
E nasce così naturalmente
La basilica del Sacré-Cœur
Che con il cimitero del Père Lachaise
È uno oggi dei punti
Come dire
Più famosi
E più visitati dai turisti
Allora anche stasera naturalmente
Come nelle serate scorse
Il nostro compito è di provare a capire
Come si è arrivati
A un parossismo di violenza
E di sangue
Come quello
Come si è arrivati
A un bagno di sangue
Che non è uguali
Nella storia di Parigi
Neanche sotto il terrore
Della rivoluzione
La ghigliottina di Robespierre
Ha ammazzato molta meno gente
Della settimana di sangue
Non parliamo dell'occupazione nazista
Non c'è confronto
Quanto a numero di morti
Come ci si è arrivati
È una storia che comincia
Dieci mesi prima
Ieri per chi c'era
Ho raccontato una guerra civile
La guerra civile americana
La cui storia comincia
Trent'anni
Quarant'anni prima
La storia della comune
Non c'è bisogno di andare così indietro
Dieci mesi prima
Nessuno l'avrebbe immaginato
Nel luglio del 1870
Quando la Francia
Dell'imperatore Napoleone III
Dichiara guerra alla Prussia
Che paese è la Francia nel 1870?
È uno dei paesi più potenti del mondo
Ha già un impero coloniale in Africa
Ha approfittato in pieno
Come gli Stati Uniti
Che evocavo ieri
Della grandiosa crescita economica
Industriale dell'Ottocento
Nei vent'anni di regno di Napoleone III
La produzione industriale in Francia
È raddoppiata
Chi c'era ieri ricorderà
Che negli Stati Uniti
Era raddoppiata in dieci anni
Però devo dire
Che anche raddoppiare in vent'anni
Noi ci metteremo la firma
Credo
È un paese evidentemente
In grandiosa crescita
Parigi in quegli anni
È stata rifatta
Dal barone Osman
Che come vorrà poi fare Mussolini a Roma
Su scala minore
Ha demolito il centro di Parigi
Ha demolito i vecchi quartieri medievali
Ha creato la Parigi moderna
Dei Grand Boulevard
Non a tutti piace
Ci sono a Parigi due fratelli
Due letterati
I fratelli Goncourt
Che tengono un diario
Che per noi è una fonte preziosissima
Per sapere così
Gli umori quotidiani
Della classe dirigente parigina
Ai fratelli Goncourt
La nuova Parigi imperiale
Creata dal barone Osman
Piace poco
Una Babilonia americana
Del futuro
Questa Parigi
Questa Babilonia
Ha due milioni di abitanti
Che in parte sono operai
Che una volta abitavano
Nel vecchio centro
Nelle catapecchie del centro
Adesso sono stati scacciati
Ricacciati
Nei quartieri
Nei nuovi ghetti operai
Diremmo noi oggi
Dell'est
L'apparenza di questa Francia imperiale
È splendida
L'esercito si considera invincibile
E grandi guerre sono state vinte
Pensateci
La guerra di Crimea
La guerra in Italia
Quella che noi chiamiamo
La seconda guerra di indipendenza
E tuttavia
Il trono dell'imperatore
Non è solido
Nonostante le apparenze
Intanto l'imperatore Napoleone III
È un usurpatore
E lo sa
Era stato eletto
Presidente della Repubblica
Vent'anni prima
E poi con un colpo di Stato
Si è proclamato imperatore
È un vecchio cospiratore
Che da giovane flertava
Con le rivoluzioni
Con i carbonari
Poi è andato al potere
Naturalmente
Ha impiantato
Un regime autoritario
Poliziesco
A contro
Un po' tutti
La destra monarchica
Nostalgica
Degli Orlean
Della monarchia
Di Luigi Filippo
E a contro
La sinistra
I repubblicani
Napoleone è uno
Che naviga vista
È stato un abile politico
Da giovane
Cerca di dare un colpo
Al cerchio
E uno alla botte
Ogni tanto
Cerca di presentarsi
Sotto una veste liberale
Anche se i giornali
Sono controllati
E la polizia bastona
Però
Ogni tanto
Napoleone III
Vorrebbe fare delle riforme
Avvicinarsi
Alle esigenze
Anche degli operai
Delle masse
Fa molta fatica
Come disse
Napoleone III
A un ambasciatore straniero
È difficile
Fare le riforme
In Francia
Facciamo le rivoluzioni
Non le riforme
E proprio perché
Di nuove rivoluzioni
L'imperatore
Non ha nessuna voglia
Ecco
Come dire
La nuova Parigi
È stata pensata
Anche per quello
Le strade
Sono asfaltate
Così non ci sono più
I san pietrini
Che la gente
I cubetti di porfido
Può tirar via
Per tirare poi
Le pietre alla polizia
E i nuovi boulevard
Del prefetto Osman
Sono stati pensati
Anche dicendo
Poi noi possiamo
Mettere due cannoni
In fondo
E voglio vedere
E se dobbiamo
Spostare le truppe
La cavalleria
In fretta
Per reprimere
I cortei
Dei rivoluzionari
I grandi boulevard
Servono per quello
Come vi dicevo
Napoleone
Che ha impiantato
Un regime autoritario
Però è sempre tentato
Di dimostrare
Invece un volto liberale
E in particolare
Negli ultimi anni
Lo ha fatto
Ha dato libertà
Di associazione
Libertà di stampa
Troppo tardi
Certe volte
Quando un regime autoritario
Comincia ad allentare
La presa
Il risultato
È il contrario
Di quello
Che ci si aspettava
Non so
A me viene in mente
Garbaciov
E la perestroica
Comincia a mollare
E di colpo
Tutti cominciano
A prendersela con te
La stampa satirica
Scandalistica
Adesso che in teoria
È libera
Comincia ad attaccare
L'imperatore
La famiglia imperiale
A quel punto
Naturalmente
I giornali
Vengono chiusi
I giornalisti
Vengono arrestati
Ma il male
È fatto
L'imperatore
Ha dimostrato
Di essere debole
E per di più
L'imperatore
È personalmente debole
È invecchiato
Non sta bene
È malato
Di calcoli
Insomma
Sotto la facciata
Splendida
E coloratissima
Molti pensano
Che l'impero
Sia allo stremo
Nel 1869
All'ultimo grande ballo
In maschera
Dato dalla corte
L'imperatrice Eugenia
Si presenta
Vestita
Da Maria Antonietta
Per molti
È uno sbaglio
Come minimo
È una gaffa
Per non dire
Un cattivo presagio
Il ministro
Degli esteri inglese
Lord Clarendon
Che per il mestiere
Che fa
Dovrebbe essere
La persona più informata
Del mondo
Annota
Ho la sensazione
Che quelli
Prima di un anno
Scivoleranno
Nella Repubblica
L'odio
Per Napoleone
Terzo
È talmente
Diffuso
Che possono
Capitare cose
Come questa
Gennaio
In un banchetto
Repubblicano
Si brinda
Alla pallottola
Che libererà
La Francia
Da Napoleone
Terzo
La polizia
Ha i suoi informatori
Prende nota
Non fa niente
Ma in realtà
Non ci sarà
Nessuna pallottola
Saranno i prussiani
Che libereranno
La Francia
Da Napoleone
Terzo
Perché in quell'estate
Estate 70
C'è uno scontro
Diplomatico
Tra la Francia
E la Prussia
Il motivo
Non dovremmo neanche
Entrare nel dettaglio
Ma ve lo dico
La Spagna
Come le è spesso
Capitato nei secoli
È senza re
Bisogna mettere d'accordo
I vari paesi d'Europa
E trovare un principe
Che vada a fare
Il re di Spagna
La Prussia
Propone
Un suo candidato
Un principe tedesco
La Francia
Si offende moltissimo
Che questi tedeschi
Possano pensare
Di mettere
Uno dei loro
Sul trono di Spagna
Che è stato
Dei Borboni
Quindi
La stampa francese
Comincia a protestare
Contro la prepotenza
Prussiana
E pretende
Che si dia
Una bella lezione
A questi prussiani
E la corte imperiale
Vede in questo
Conflitto diplomatico
Con la Prussia
L'occasione
Per far vedere
Che noi
Siamo ancora
Forti
Capaci
Di farci sentire
L'imperatrice
Eugenia
Parlando con
L'imperatore
Napoleone III
Gli mostra
Il figlio
E gli dice
Se vuoi
Che questo ragazzo
Regni
Devi dare
Una lezione
Alla Prussia
Ora
Questo vuol dire
Che si aspettano
Di fare la faccia dura
E che la Prussia
Spaventata
Farà un passo indietro
Ma la Prussia
Che poi vuol dire
Il cancelliere
Otto von Bismarck
La Prussia
Non ha nessuna paura
E anzi
Vuole lo scontro
Perché la Prussia
Sta completando
L'unificazione
Della Germania
Quattro anni prima
C'è stata la guerra
Contro l'Austria
Centriamo anche noi
E la nostra terza guerra
D'indipendenza
Ma non l'abbiamo vinta
Noi
L'hanno vinta i prussiani
E la Prussia
Ha bisogno ancora
Di un'altra vittoria
Per convincere
Tutti gli stati tedeschi
A unificarsi
In un grande impero
A guida prussiana
E questa vittoria
Il cancelliere
Von Bismarck
È convinto
Di poterla ottenere
Contro la grande potenza
Del continente
La Francia
Quindi
Quando
Quando la Francia
Dice alla Prussia
Che devono rinunciare
I prussiani
Alla loro candidatura
La Prussia
Rifiuta
Con un messaggio
Che Bismarck
Volutamente
Fa formulare
Nel modo
Più scortese
E offensivo
Possibile
La stampa francese
Perde completamente
La testa
E il 19 luglio
La Francia
Dichiara guerra
Alla Prussia
In apparenza
Il calcolo
Di Napoleone
Terzo
Riesce
L'opinione
Pubblica
Di colpo
In Francia
È entusiasta
Di questa guerra
Pochi
Non sono d'accordo
Uno è Flaubert
Avete presente
Madame Bovary
Uno dei grandi
Scrittori francesi
Dell'epoca
Nonché l'autore
Del dizionario
Dei luoghi comuni
Flaubert
Annota
Sono sconvolto
Dalla stupidità
Dei miei compatrioti
Ma pochissimi
Neanche Flaubert
Forse
Capiscono
Che il vero problema
È che
I francesi
Saranno sconfitti
Perché la Prussia
Militarmente
Senza che nessuno
Se ne sia accorto
Ha accumulato
Una potenza militare
Di fronte a cui
La Francia
Non ha nessuna speranza
C'è uno che lo sa
È l'ambasciatore
Francese
Washington
Si chiama
Prévost
Paradol
L'ambasciatore
Prévost
Paradol
Da molto tempo
È ossessionato
Dalla crescita
Della potenza
Della Germania
Alla notizia
Che abbiamo
Dichiarato guerra
Alla Prussia
L'ambasciatore
Francese
Washington
Scrive a Parigi
Per avvertirli
Che saranno
Schiacciati
Dai prussiani
Dopodiché
Si ammazza
Con una pistolettata
In testa
E infatti
Puntualmente
La guerra
Va malissimo
Già
Ai primi
Di agosto
Dal fronte
Arrivano
Notizie
Di sconfitte
Disastrose
E Parigi
Piomba
Nella costernazione
Da uno stato
D'animo
Di entusiasmo
Collettivo
Si piomba
Nel panico
I rari tedeschi
Che si aggirano
Ancora per le strade
Di Parigi
Vengono aggrediti
Per la strada
Al Bois de Boulogne
Si comincia
Ad abbattere
Alberi
Per erigere
Barricate
E difendere
La città
Se arrivano
I prussiani
Ma soprattutto
La piazza
Si riempie
Di gente
Che protesta
Contro il governo
Il 9 agosto
L'imperatrice
Eugenia
Telegrafa
Al marito
Che è al fronte
Per informarlo
Che la sommossa
Ormai
È quasi
In piazza
Ci sono testimonianze
Che descrivono
Per esempio
Place de la Concorde
Stracolma
Di gente
Pochi borghesi
E molti
Colletti neri
Quelli che noi
Chiamiamo piuttosto
Blue collar
Molti operai
Tutti parlano
Apertamente
Contro il governo
Si levano
Grida
Viva la repubblica
Al fronte
L'imperatore
È ancora lì
Al fronte
Con l'esercito
Che sta venendo
Via via
Respinto
E sconfitto
Chi vede
L'imperatore
Lo giudica
Un uomo
Finito
A Parigi
Vengono reclutati
Rapidamente
Battaglioni di milizia
Per rafforzare
L'esercito
Arrivano
Al fronte
I loro ufficiali
Gli ordinano
Gridate
Vive l'empereur
La risposta
È
Un
Deux
Trois
Merde
L'imperatore
Scrive a Eugenia
Per sapere
Se non è meglio
Che lui torni a Parigi
Per tenere sotto controllo
Almeno il Parlamento
L'opinione pubblica
Eugenia
Gli scrive
In questa situazione
Se torni a Parigi
Sarà la rivoluzione
Perciò
Napoleone
Rimane con l'esercito
Fino all'ultimo
Cioè
Fino al 2 settembre
Quando il grosso
Dell'esercito francese
Con il suo imperatore
È circondato
Dai prussiani
E capitola
A Sedan
E l'imperatore
È prigioniero
Dei prussiani
2 settembre
La notizia
Arriva a Parigi
La sera
Del 3 settembre
I diaristi
Di cui vi parlavamo
I fratelli Goncourt
Beh uno in realtà
È appena morto
Ne resta un altro
Edmond
Edmond de Goncourt
Nel suo diario
Descrive Parigi
La sera
Del 3 settembre
L'arrivo
Dei giornali
La folla
Intorno alle edicole
Tutti che aspettano
Onsiosamente
Il giornale
Poi
I lettori
Che si ammassano
All'aperto
Sotto i lampioni
A gas
Uno che legge
E tutti gli altri
Che stanno a sentire
E sentendo
Queste notizie
L'esercito
Catturato
L'imperatore
Prigioniero
Edmond de Goncourt
Descrive
Prima il silenzio
E sterrefatto
Di quelli che non ci credono
Poi il mormorio minaccioso
Che comincia a crescere
E poi le grida
Abdicazione
Viva la Repubblica
Morte all'imperatore
Il giorno dopo
4 settembre
La folla
Marcia sul Parlamento
E sul municipio
Di Parigi
E proclama
La Repubblica
L'imperatrice Eugenia
Fugge da Parigi
Travestita
Su una carrozza
Che le ha imprestato
Il suo dentista
I ministri
Fuggono
All'estero
Succede quello
Che succede
Alla fine
Di ogni regime
Vengono scalpellate
Le aquile
E le n
Colossali
N per Napoleone
Di pietra
Che c'erano dappertutto
Si va su
E si scalpellano
Si buttano giù
In strada le aquile
Sul portone
Delle tuilerie
Il principale palazzo
Dell'imperatore
Qualcuno scarabocchia
Col gesso
Proprietà del popolo
Ma in realtà
Non è ancora
Una rivoluzione sociale
Non ci sono
Né violenze
Né saccheggi
E non è
Appunto
Non è nient'altro
Che l'instaurazione
Della Repubblica
E all'idea
Che c'è la Repubblica
A Parigi
Il clima generale
È di euforia
Non c'è violenza
Non c'è repressione
Le truppe fraternizzano
Con la popolazione
Si canta
La marsigliese
Il fatto è che
La Repubblica
È nella pancia
Di Parigi
E da sempre
La Repubblica
È vista
Come
Come la soluzione
Di tutti i mali
C'è una testimonianza
Di uno dei grandi
Letterati francesi
Dell'epoca
Verlaine
Grande poeta
Peraltro giovanissimo
Verlaine
Ha 26 anni
Si è sposato
Un mese prima
Sua moglie
Ha 17 anni
E Verlaine
Divorzieranno
Pochissimo tempo dopo
Fra l'altro
Ma Verlaine
Ci racconta
Mia moglie
Quando si è sparsa
La notizia
Mi ha detto
La Repubblica
Adesso che ce l'abbiamo
È tutto a posto
Vero
Perfino i prussiani
Non fanno più paura
Un operaio
Dichiara
Adesso che l'abbiamo
Quelli là
Non oseranno
Venire
Perché nella Repubblica
Ci si identifica
La sensazione è
La Repubblica
Siamo tutti
E se siamo tutti insieme
Non abbiamo paura
Di nessuno
In realtà
Capite
La Repubblica
Ha dei grossi vizi
D'origine
Primo
È un nuovo governo
Che è stato formato
A Parigi
Senza minimamente
Preoccuparsi
Di cosa pensa
Il resto della Francia
A Parigi
Neanche lo sanno
Che c'è il resto della Francia
È una vecchia storia
Parigi
E la Francia profonda
Sono due mondi
Molto diversi
Lo sono sempre stati
Lo sono anche oggi
E sono in genere
In pessimi rapporti
La Francia profonda
Non è repubblicana
È monarchica
Cattolica
Conservatrice
E detesta Parigi
Ma a Parigi
Non se ne accorgono
Hanno fatto
La Repubblica
E la sentono
Come la Repubblica
Francese
E poi
Il secondo problema
È che i repubblicani
Sono divisi
Essere repubblicani
Non è una definizione
Sufficiente
Per andare d'accordo
I repubblicani
Hanno in comune
L'odio per Napoleone III
Una concezione
Laica
Dello Stato
Anticlericale
Ma per il resto
I repubblicani
Sono in parte
Borghesia
Moderata
Conservatrice
Anzi
Che vuole la Repubblica
Perché la sente
Come la forma
Più utile
Per lei
Di governo
E dall'altra
Ci sono quelli
Che già all'epoca
Chiamano normalmente
I rossi
I sovversivi
Dei quartieri operai
Sono repubblicani
Sia i rossi
Di Belville
Di Montmartre
Sia gli avvocati
Borghesi
I proprietari
Dei quartieri
Bene
Di Parigi
Ovest
E il governo
Repubblicano
È un governo
Borghese
Tutto fatto
Di liberali
Borghesi
Moderati
Per lo più avvocati
La presidenza
E poi la preoccupazione
Appunto
È di chiarire bene
Al paese
Che questa repubblica
Non è rivoluzionaria
Assolutamente
Non bisogna aver paura
Bisogna trovare
Un presidente
Della repubblica
Offrono la presidenza
A un generale
Il generale
Trochu
Governatore
Militare
Di Parigi
Il quale accetta
La presidenza
Ma chiede
Una garanzia
La garanzia
Che il nuovo
Governo
Difenderà
La religione
La proprietà
E la famiglia
E nel suo primo
Discorso pubblico
Il nuovo presidente
Della repubblica
Rassicura
I francesi
Si proclama
Soldato
Cattolico
E bretone
Dove la Bretagna
L'Ovest
È da sempre
La culla
Della contro
Rivoluzione
Della vandea
Della conservazione
Appunto
Cattolica
E monarchica
La sensazione
In realtà
È che
Questa repubblica
Riesce
A nascere
Riesce a nascere
Perché in realtà
Anche i monarchici
Nella situazione
In cui ci si trova
E cioè
Stiamo perdendo
Vergognosamente
Una guerra
Catastrofica
E dovremo fare
Una pace
Vergognosa
Con il nemico
Vittorioso
Allora probabilmente
Il calcolo
Di molti è
Facciamolo fare
Alla repubblica
Quando la repubblica
Si sarà sporcata
Le mani
E avrà fatto
La pace
Poi vedremo
E queste
Sono le posizioni
Dei moderati
Però a Parigi
A Parigi
Gran parte
Degli abitanti
Sono operai
E loro non sono
Moderati
Secondo l'ultimo
Censimento
Gli operai
Sono mezzo milione
A Parigi
L'orario di lavoro
È di undici ore
Al giorno
E i salari
Sono talmente bassi
Che l'intera
Popolazione operaia
Vive in povertà
I quartieri
Dove sono ammassati
Appunto all'est
Sono quartieri
Dove la polizia
Non si fa vedere
E però
Non sono luoghi
Di delinquenza
Sono luoghi
Dove sta crescendo
Una certa
Consapevolezza
Politica
Da anni
Da quando l'imperatore
Ha concesso
La libertà
Di associazione
Nei quartieri
Operai
Si tengono
Riunioni
Per parlare
Di politica
Di socialismo
Per parlare
Dei diritti
Delle donne
Si moltiplicano
Le cooperative
Le società
Di mutuo soccorso
E ci sono
Le sezioni
Dell'internazionale
Socialista
Della grande
Organizzazione
Internazionale
Appunto
Che Marx
Ha fondato
A Londra
Napoleone III
Ha concesso
Tutto questo
Pensando sotto sotto
Anziché
Le riunioni
Clandestine
Dei carbonari
E lui
Quando era giovane
Partecipava
A quelle riunioni
Clandestine
Molto meglio
Associazioni
Registrate
Che la polizia
Sa dove
Trovarli
Può infiltrare
I suoi informatori
Però sta di fatto
Che questo enorme
Mondo operaio
È tutto
Un tessuto
Di associazioni
Di riunioni
Ora voi capite
Una folla di poveri
Non organizzati
Non conta niente
Ma quando invece
Cominciano a essere organizzati
Avere dei capi
Dei portavoce
Le cose
Cambiano
E infatti
La notizia
Della catastrofe
È arrivata
Il 3 settembre
Il 4 settembre
Viene proclamata
La Repubblica
Già il 5 settembre
Si tiene
Una riunione
Dei delegati
Dell'internazionale
Socialista
Delle associazioni
Operai
E delle cooperative
Che tutti insieme
Istituiscono
Comitati di vigilanza
Nei quartieri
Questa è la differenza
Quando appunto
Una folla
È già
In precedenza
Organizzata
E quindi pronta
A muoversi
In modo organizzato
E non sono solo
Organizzati
Gli operai di Parigi
Sono anche armati
Legalmente armati
Perché
In Francia
Come nell'Italia
Dell'epoca
Esiste
Una istituzione
Che si chiama
La Guardia Nazionale
È una tipica
Istituzione
Ottocentesca
Negli Stati Uniti
Esiste ancora adesso
Come sapete
È un'associazione
Di volontari
Praticamente
Volontari
Che prestano
Un certo servizio
Militare
Che sono armati
Dal governo
Inquadrati
Regolarmente
Part time
Anzi
Proprio
Nel tempo libero
E nel
Nel mondo
Dell'Ottocento
È una tipica
Organizzazione
Borghese
Che serve
A mantenere
L'ordine pubblico
Dando una certa
Garanzia
Di partecipazione
Di adesione
In Italia
Per esempio
Capite di che anni
Stiamo parlando
La lotta
Il brigantaggio
Sta appena
Uscendo
Dalla sua fase
Più violenta
E nella guerra
Civile
Che si è combattuta
Nell'Italia meridionale
Contro il brigantaggio
La Guardia Nazionale
Reclutata
Fra i proprietari
Possidenti
Borghesi
Delle cittadine
Del sud
Ha avuto
Un ruolo fondamentale
Accanto all'esercito
Anche in Francia
La Guardia Nazionale
Nasce come
Un'organizzazione
Borghese
E quindi
Conservatrice
C'è l'aneddoto
Di un inglese
Che va a trovare
Il barone Rothschild
Il più ricco
Banchiere del mondo
E lo trova
Nella sua uniforme
Della Guardia Nazionale
Perché è normale
I borghesi
Fanno parte
Della Guardia Nazionale
Ma da quando
È scoppiata
La guerra
Contro la Prussia
Il governo
Dell'imperatore
Ha pensato
Che era meglio
Allargare
La Guardia Nazionale
Reclutare
Più gente
E ha offerto
Un soldo
Un franco e mezzo
Al giorno
A chi voleva
Arruolarsi
Nella Guardia Nazionale
Ora
Un franco e mezzo
Al giorno
È molto meno
Della paga
Di un operaio
Però da quando
È scoppiata la guerra
C'è la crisi
Gli operai
Vengono licenziati
In massa
Non hanno più
Da mangiare
Si arruolano
Nella Guardia Nazionale
In poche settimane
La Guardia Nazionale
Di Parigi
Arriva a
300.000
Iscritti
A ognuno
Dei quali
Il governo
Dà una divisa
E un fucile
E la maggioranza
Di loro
Sono reclutati
Nei quartieri
Operai
E eleggono
I loro ufficiali
Vedendo che succede
Questo
La borghesia
Comincia a spaventarsi
Le prime
Ci sono le prime
Testimonianze
Di gente
Che dice
Ma siamo sicuri
Va bene che c'è la guerra
Che conviene
Mettere i fucili
In mano agli operai
Del resto
In quei giorni
Marx
Scriverà
Comunque
Finisca
La guerra
Ha insegnato
Al proletariato
Francese
A usare
Le armi
E questa
È la migliore
Garanzia
Per il futuro
Comunque
Finisca
La guerra
Non è finita
L'imperatore
È stato catturato
Si è arreso
Ma la guerra
Non è affatto finita
Non è stato firmato niente
L'avanzata
Dei prussiani
Continua
Il nuovo governo
Repubblicano
Ha un chiaro mandato
Finire la guerra
Il prima possibile
Anche
Anche perché
Finendo la guerra
Forse potremmo
Sciogliere la guardia nazionale
E ritirare le armi
Agli operai
Prima che sia
Troppo tardi
Però
Però capite
Un conto è dire
Va bene
Vogliamo finire la guerra
Ma i prussiani
Ci daranno
Delle condizioni
Accettabili
Si cercano
Dei mediatori
Il 6 settembre
Due dei principali
Esponenti
Del governo
Repubblicano
Incontrano
L'ambasciatore inglese
Lord Lyons
Questi due esponenti
Li menzioneremo
Ancora spesso
Uno è il ministro
Degli esteri
Favre
Jules Favre
E l'altro
Si chiama
Thier
Adolphe Thier
È un
Intellettuale
Molto noto
Uno storico
Famoso
Ma soprattutto
È un politico
Di lungo corso
Ha 73 anni
Ed è in politica
Da 50 anni
È conosciuto
Come monarchico
Orleanista
È stato presidente
Del consiglio
Tre volte
Sotto la vecchia
Monarchia
Poi è stato
Poi è stato un oppositore
Di Napoleone
Terzo
E adesso
È uno degli uomini
Di spicco
Del nuovo governo
Repubblicano
Thier
Va dall'ambasciatore inglese
Pregandolo
Di far intervenire
L'Inghilterra
Per convincere
I prussiani
A concederci
Una pace
Ragionevole
Non troppo
Vergognosa
E Thier
Sottolinea
Ne abbiamo bisogno
Perché a Parigi
C'è il pericolo
Rosso
Ma intanto
La guerra
Continua
I tedeschi
Stanno invadendo
La Francia
E Parigi
Si prepara
All'assedio
Parigi
È difesa
Da una cerchia
Di fortificazioni
Gigantesca
Che proprio
Thier
Ha fatto costruire
Quando era ministro
Sotto Luigi Filippo
È difficilissimo
Conquistare Parigi
Con la forza
Ci si prepara
A essere assediati
Il che vuol dire
Dar da mangiare
A due milioni
Di persone
Si fanno venire
In città
Greggi di pecore
Mandri
E di bovini
Tutti i parchi
Di Parigi
Si riempiono
Di bestiame
Le opere d'arte
Del Louvre
Vengono evacuate
In provincia
A rischio
Bombardamenti
E si scavano
Fosse comuni
Perché un assedio
Per quanto si ricordano
Loro dal
Passato
Vuole sempre dire
Che prima o poi
Scoppia un'epidemia
Quelli che possono
Scappano
Molti ricchi
Da Parigi
Ma in compenso
In città
Arriva una folla
Di giornalisti
Naturalmente
Arrivano giornalisti
Da tutta Europa
Per raccontare
L'assedio
Che si prepara
Arrivano i turisti
Stranieri
Che vogliono
Concedersi
Lo spettacolo
Dell'assedio
Ci sono inserzioni
Sui giornali
Io le ho viste
Appartamenti
A prova di bomba
Con rifugio
Sotterraneo
Per i signori
Inglesi
Che desiderano
Assistere
All'assedio
Di Parigi
E il 19
Settembre
I prussiani
Sono alle porte
Di Parigi
E comincia
L'assedio
Il ministro
Il ministro degli esteri
Jules Favre
Va da Bismarck
A chiedere
Quali sono
Le condizioni
Per la pace
E Bismarck
Espone le condizioni
Che sono durissime
Alcuno di voi
Se lo ricorderà
Perché da queste condizioni
Nasce poi
Il revanchismo
Francese
La voglia di vendetta
Che porterà
Fra gli altri motivi
Alla prima guerra mondiale
La Germania
La Prussia
Che sta per diventare
L'impero di Germania
Vuole che la Francia
Ceda
Due intere regioni
La Sazia
E la Lorena
Due grandi regioni
Di confine
Apprendendo
Che le condizioni
Sono queste
Il ministro degli esteri
Francese
Favre
Scoppia a piangere
Peraltro
Bismarck
Dirà poi
Pareva che piangesse
E io cercai
Di consolarlo
Ma guardandolo
Più da vicino
Mi resi conto
Che non aveva versato
Neanche una lacrima
Probabilmente
Voleva commuovermi
Con questa messa in scena
Come fanno
Gli avvocati
Parigini
In tribunale
Perciò
La pace
Per il momento
Non viene firmata
E Parigi
È assediata
L'assedio
Dura quattro mesi
Da settembre
A gennaio
L'assedio
Ovviamente
Vuol dire la fame
Si mangiano
I cani
I gatti
Notate
Non di straforo
Ufficialmente
Ci sono le foto
Delle nuove
Macellerie
Macelleria
Canina
E felina
Si mangiano
I topi
Gli elefanti
Dello zoo
E i cammelli
Del jardin
De plant
La città
Tira avanti
La mortalità
Sale
Ovviamente
Nei mesi
Dell'assedio
A Parigi
L'anagrafe
Registra
42.000
Morti
In più
Rispetto
All'anno precedente
Muoiono i bambini
Specialmente
I bambini piccoli
Non c'è latte
Oltretutto
A dicembre
Il freddo
È glaciale
Si va
Da meno
Cinque
A meno
Noventi
A Parigi
La Senna
Gela
Per tre settimane
La Senna
È completamente
Gelata
I prussiani
Stanno fuori
Parigi
È difesa
Da una grande
Cerchia di
Fortificazioni
E nessuno
Ha voglia di
Attaccare
I prussiani
Stanno fuori
E aspettano
Che Parigi
Si arrenda
Poi a gennaio
Vedendo che
Nonostante tutto
Parigi
Non si arrende
I prussiani
Decidono di
Stringere un po'
E cominciano
A bombardare
Il 5 gennaio
L'artiglieria
Tedesca
Comincia a bombardare
La città
Ammazzando
La gente
Per la strada
E Parigi
Ribolle
Di ansia
Di angoscia
Di preoccupazione
E soprattutto
Di sospetto
Perché le masse
Operaie
Sono per resistere
A tutti i costi
Questo ci può anche
Stupire magari
Dopotutto
Marx aveva fondato
L'internazionale
E diceva
Proletari
Di tutto il mondo
Unitevi
Ma in realtà
Queste masse
Operaie
Di Parigi
Sono anche
Furiosamente
Nazionaliste
E non vogliono
Assolutamente
La resa
E sospettano
Il governo
Borghese
Di essere pronto
Invece
A svendere
La lotta
Come infatti
E ad arrendersi
C'è un dibattito
Violentissimo
In Parigi
E diventa
Sempre più chiaro
Che i quartieri
Operai
Non si fidano
Del governo
Ufficiale
Ci sono giornali
Di estrema sinistra
Che promettono
Un premio
In denaro
Per chi ammazzerà
Il re di Prussia
E già che ci sono
Per chi ammazzerà
Il presidente
Presidente della Repubblica
I giornali rossi
I politici
Rossi
Nei loro comizi
Battono
Vogliono che le chiese
Siano trasformate
In caserme
Per la Guardia Nazionale
Operaia
I preti
Che vadano al fronte
E i ricchi
Non hanno forse
Le case piene
Di roba da mangiare
Confiscare
Distribuire
Tra le mille altre cose
Una delle cose
Che i rossi chiedono
È
Chiamate Garibaldi
Mandate a chiamare Garibaldi
Che è l'unico
Che può forse
Darci una mano
E farla vedere
Ai prussiani
A questo punto
Nei quartieri borghesi
Di Parigi
Il discorso
Comincia a essere
Ma dobbiamo
Aver paura
Dei prussiani
O dobbiamo
Aver paura
Dei rossi
Forse
Dobbiamo
Aver più paura
Dei rossi
E il 6 gennaio
Compare
Sui muri
Di Parigi
Un manifesto
Rosso
Che reclama
L'istituzione
Della comune
Di Parigi
Largo al popolo
Largo
Alla comune
Cos'è la comune?
Cosa vuol dire?
Perché tutti noi
Abbiamo in mente
Questa formula
La comune
Di Parigi
Ma cosa diavolo
Vuol dire?
Io credo che inconsciamente
Molti di noi
Associano questa cosa
Al comunismo
Ma non è affatto
Così di per sé
La comune di Parigi
In francese
La comune
È il comune
Il municipio
In sostanza
La comune di Parigi
Vuol dire
Che si vuole
Che Parigi
Diventi
Un comune
Autonomo
Come potevano essere
I nostri comuni
Del medioevo
Che Parigi
Si governa
Da sola
E che la Repubblica
Francese
Sarà una federazione
Di comuni
Ognuno
Autonomo
Nella mentalità
Collettiva
Dei Parigini
È fortissima
Questa cosa
Parigi
Che se la cava
Da sola
Che si governa
E al tempo
Della rivoluzione
Francese
Era stata creata
La comune
A Parigi
Nel momento più drammatico
Nell'agosto del 92
Anche allora
Con l'invasione
Prussiana
Alle porte
Parigi
Era insorta
Aveva creato
La comune
Aveva detronizzato
Il re
E nella memoria
Popolare
La comune di Parigi
Aveva salvato
La Francia
Quindi è questo
La comune
O anche qualcosa
Di molto più vago
Perché in realtà
Tanta gente
Mica la sa
La storia
Ma questo nome
La comune
Entusiasma
Tutti
Ci sono testimonianze
Di un oratore
Che parlando
Al popolo
Dice
La comune
È il diritto
Del popolo
È il razionamento
Uguale per tutti
È la leva
In massa
La punizione
Dei traditori
La comune
È la comune
Insomma
È un ideale
Astratto
Che però
Mobilita
Le coscienze
E intanto
Il 18 gennaio
A Versailles
È stato proclamato
L'impero tedesco
La Prussia
Ha completato
Il suo percorso
Ha convinto
Tutti gli altri
Stati tedeschi
A unificarsi
In un unico
Reich
E a Parigi
Non c'è più niente
Da mangiare
Si tenta
Un'ultima sortita
Contro i prussiani
Che finisce malissimo
E a questo punto
Il governo
Decide di chiedere
La resa
Accettando
Le condizioni
Di Bismarck
Nel governo
È forte
Il timore
Che quando
La gente
Saprà
Che ci arrendiamo
Scoppi
La rivoluzione
Effettivamente
Appunto
Come vi dicevo
Nei quartieri rossi
L'idea è
Quei borghesi
Traditori
Del governo
Sono pronti
Ad arrendersi
Ai prussiani
E poi
Con loro aiuto
Schiacciare
Tutte le conquiste
Che il popolo
Può aver fatto
Quando il ministro
Degli esteri
Jules Favre
Va a Versailles
A incontrare
Bismarck
Per firmare
La resa
Il commento
Che fa
Con gli amici
Prima di andare
È il seguente
Dio solo
Sa
Cosa ci farà
La plebaglia
Parigina
Quando saremo
Costretti
A dirle
La verità
Bismarck
Riceve
Favre
E gli dice
Ma avete paura
Della guardia nazionale
Vero
Degli operai armati
Disarmate
La guardia nazionale
Favre
Gli risponde
Che è impossibile
Se tentiamo
Di togliere
I fucili
Alla guardia nazionale
Scoppia
La guerra civile
Bismarck
Siete
Degli sciocchi
Presto
Tardi
La guardia
Nazionale
Dovrà essere
Ridotta
La ragione
Non otterrete
Niente
Aspettando
Provocate
Una rivolta
Ora che avete
Ancora
Un esercito
Per reprimerla
Bismarck
Dirà poi
Favre
Mi ha guardato
Con orrore
Come se fossi
Stato un mostro
Assettato
Di sangue
Il 28 gennaio
È firmato
L'armistizio
Non è ancora
Il trattato di pace
E attenzione
Le parole
E l'armistizio
Sospendiamo
Le ostilità
E il governo
Repubblicano
Promette al popolo
Che non è ancora
Deciso niente
Adesso si va
Alle elezioni
Si elegge
Un parlamento
E il parlamento
Deciderà
Se continuare
La guerra
Oppure fare
La pace
E Parigi
È talmente affamata
Che sul momento
Non reagisce
Anzi
Meno male
Che c'è l'armistizio
I prussiani
Stessi
Cominciano a distribuire
Accelerazioni
Alla popolazione
Che sta morendo
Di fame
Poi dopo qualche giorno
Cominciano ad arrivare
I viveri donati
Dall'Inghilterra
In Inghilterra
Il governo
Associazioni private
Si sono mobilitati
Per raccogliere viveri
Da mandare a Parigi
E adesso
Che l'assedio
È finito
Altra gente
Se ne va
Se ne vanno
I giornalisti
I turisti stranieri
E anche tanti
Altri borghesi
Perché la città
È affamata
Devastata
Bombardata
Al freddo
I quartieri borghesi
Si svuotano
E con loro
Evaporano
Anche
I battaglioni
Della guardia nazionale
Che potevano essere
Fedeli al governo
Però all'inizio
Sembra che tutto
Fili liscio
8 febbraio
Elezioni
In tutta la Francia
Si vota
Per eleggere
Il nuovo Parlamento
Della Repubblica
Si vota
Voi capite
Con un terzo
Del paese
Occupato dal nemico
Con centinaia
Di migliaia
Di soldati
Che sono prigionieri
Di guerra
E quindi non votano
Con una campagna elettorale
Che dura pochi giorni
Il grande tema
Della campagna elettorale
È
Volete la pace
O volete la guerra
E tutta la Francia
Elegge
Candidati
Che vogliono la pace
Tranne Parigi
Parigi
Elegge
Candidati
Che vogliono
Continuare la guerra
I candidati pacifisti
Della Francia profonda
Sono in genere
Conservatori
Monarchici
Cattolici
Solo a Parigi
I rossi
Eleggono deputati
Che invece
Vogliono continuare
La resistenza
Tra gli altri
A Parigi
Viene eletto
Garibaldi
Il quale
Quando poi si presenta
All'assemblea nazionale
Scopre che
C'è qualche legge
Da qualche parte
Che dice
Che se uno non è francese
Non può essere deputato
In realtà
Il problema
È che l'assemblea nazionale
Garibaldi
Non lo vuole per niente
Perché il nuovo parlamento
È conservatore
Monarchico
Cattolico
Anche i deputati
Che arrivano da Parigi
Vengono accolti malissimo
Il Parlamento
Non è a Parigi
Naturalmente
Parigi era stata assediata
Il Parlamento
Si riunisce a Bordeaux
I deputati
Che arrivano da Parigi
Cioè dalla capitale
Rossa
Rivoluzionaria
Atea
Sono accolti
Malissimo
Da un Parlamento
Che rappresenta
La grande maggioranza
Dei francesi
Conservatori
Cattolici
E in parte
Anche monarchici
Il 17 febbraio
Viene formato il governo
Presidente del Consiglio
Thiers
Che abbiamo già incontrato prima
Lo stesso che aveva detto
A Lord Lyons
Se l'Inghilterra
Non ci dà una mano
A fare la pace presto
A Parigi
C'è il pericolo rosso
La nomina
Presidente del Consiglio
Di Thiers
Crea sgomento
A Parigi
Perché Thiers
È considerato
Un reazionario
Feroce
In parte lo è
Quando era ministro
Sotto Luigi Filippo
Ha soffocato nel sangue
Manifestazioni popolari
Poi è cambiato
Non è più monarchico
È diventato repubblicano
È convinto
Che il futuro
È della Repubblica
Ma ovviamente
È una Repubblica borghese
Conservatrice
Solida
Che difenda
La proprietà
E la religione
Non certo
Quello che vuole
La plebaglia rossa
Di Parigi
In ogni caso
La notizia
Che il Presidente
Del Consiglio
È Thiers
Che ha la fama
Di un aristocratico
Snob
Che disprezza
La plebaglia
Ecco
Questa notizia
Crea a Parigi
Un clima rivoluzionario
La Guardia Nazionale
Sfila a Parigi
Alla notizia
Della creazione
Del governo Thiers
La Guardia Nazionale
Sfila a Parigi
Con le bandiere
Listate a lutto
La parata
Dura otto ore
Nei discorsi
Si richiamano
Il 93
Il 30
Il 48
Tutti gli anni
Delle grandi rivoluzioni
E nei discorsi
Si minacciano
I borghesi
Avete fatto
Il vostro governo
Pare che gli sfruttatori
Si siano dimenticati
Che a volte
Il popolo
Si risveglia
Improvvisamente
Il 26 febbraio
Thiers firma
Il trattato
Di pace
E per rassicurare
Il popolo
Già durante le trattative
Si era garantito
Il nemico
Non entrerà
A Parigi
Cioè avrete
Questa soddisfazione
Simbolica
La città
Anche se ci arrendiamo
Verrà rispettata
Invece
Alla fine
Nel trattato di pace
I prussiani
Impongono
Il diritto
Di fare
Una bella
Sfilata
Della vittoria
Sotto l'arco
Di trionfo
E sugli Champs-Élysées
Il primo marzo
I prussiani
Sfilano
Sugli Champs-Élysées
E occupano
Parte di Parigi
Ma non si spingono
Fino ai quartieri
Operai
Dell'Est
A questo punto
Con i prussiani
Dentro Parigi
Thiers
Va da Bismarck
E in sostanza
Gli dice
Adesso che ci siete
Ci aiutate
Vero
A disarmare
La Guardia Nazionale
A domare
I quartieri
Operai
Bismarck
Fa capire
Che loro
Non sono lì
Per togliergli
Le castagne
Dal fuoco
Che si arrangiassero
Loro
Dopo due giorni
I prussiani
Escono
Da Parigi
Ma nel trattato
Di pace
I generali
Prussiani
Hanno imposto
Che le forze
Regolari
Francesi
Venissero sciolte
Perciò
Il governo
Non ha
Forze
Armate
L'unica forza
Armata
A Parigi
È la Guardia
Nazionale
In mano
Agli operai
L'Assemblea
Nazionale
È sempre
A Bordeaux
Anche il governo
Voi capite
Che una situazione
Del genere
È già una situazione
Dove basta
Niente
Per far scoppiare
Chissà cosa
In una situazione
Del genere
Il nuovo Parlamento
L'Assemblea
Nazionale
A Bordeaux
Comincia
A varare
Una serie
Di leggi
Che sembrano
Fatte apposta
Per far saltare
Tutto in aria
E quindi
Condanna a morte
In contumacia
Di parecchi capi
Della sinistra
Chiusura
Dei giornali
Di sinistra
Ma soprattutto
Durante la guerra
Era stato decretato
Il blocco
Degli sfratti
Degli affitti
La moratoria
Dei debiti
Adesso
Che la guerra
È finita
La prima cosa
Che il Parlamento
Fa
È di abolire
Il blocco
Degli affitti
Degli sfratti
La moratoria
Sui debiti
Da un giorno
All'altro
Una marea
Di operai
Ma anche
Di bottegai
Artigiani
Si ritrova
In mezzo
Alla strada
Sfrattata
Senza poter
Pagare i debiti
E così via
Come se non bastasse
L'Assemblea Nazionale
Decide che
Adesso che la guerra
È finita
È inutile
Continuare a pagare
Quel soldo
Di un franco
Al giorno
Che si paga
Ai membri
Della Guardia Nazionale
Dopo aver fatto
Tutte queste leggi
Il governo
Torna a Parigi
L'Assemblea Nazionale
Lascia Bordeaux
Ma non osa
Entrare a Parigi
E si ferma
A Versailles
Che dal punto di vista
Simbolico
Capite
Non è neanche quella
La scelta migliore
È l'antica
Come dire
Residenza
Dei re
Dove fino a ieri
Stavano il re di Prussia
E Bismarck
Lì
Sotto la protezione
Delle baionette prussiane
Prende posizione
Il nuovo Parlamento
Francese
Che non ha il coraggio
Di entrare in Parigi
E a questo punto
A questo punto
È tutto appeso a un filo
E Thierre
Pensa
E Thierre pensa
Come dire
Accettando tardivamente
Il consiglio di Bismarck
Che forse adesso
Si può tentare
La prova di forza
E disarmare
La Guardia Nazionale
Non ha quasi più truppe
Ma qualche reparto
I prussiani
Gliel'hanno lasciato
Per mantenere
L'ordine pubblico
E con le poche truppe
A disposizione
Thierre decide
Di disarmare
La Guardia Nazionale
Cominciando dai cannoni
Perché la Guardia Nazionale
Non sono soltanto
Decine di battaglioni
Di volontari
Armati di moschetto
È un vero esercito
Ha la sua artiglieria
Comprata con
Sottoscrizione popolare
Durante la guerra
Proprietà della Guardia Nazionale
Neanche i prussiani
Le hanno toccati
Quei cannoni
Sono un'enorme quantità
Di cannoni
Ammassati
Sulla collina
Di Montmartre
E Thierre
Presidente del consiglio
Il 18 marzo
Data che se poi
Andate a vedere
È rimasta
Diciamo
Nella storia
Della Francia
Come il giorno
In cui è cominciata
Veramente
Ufficialmente
La rivoluzione
Il 18 marzo
Thierre manda
Il generale
Le Comte
Con le poche truppe
Di cui dispone
A impadronirsi
Dei cannoni
Della Guardia Nazionale
Le truppe del governo
Circondano
La collina
Di Montmartre
Poi all'alba
Cominciano a portare giù
I cannoni
La gente
Se ne accorge
Suonano le campane
A martello
La gente
Comincia ad arrivare
La Guardia Nazionale
Si arma
La folla
Preme minacciosamente
Contro i soldati
Il generale
Le Comte
Ordina
La truppa
Di aprire
Il fuoco
Contro la Guardia Nazionale
E contro la folla
I soldati
Rifiutano
Di sparare
Fraternizzano
Con la folla
La folla
Dilaga
Nel centro
Di Parigi
E pianta
La bandiera
Rossa
Sulla colonna
Della Bastiglia
E sul municipio
Sull'hotel
Deville
E qui si colloca
Il primo
Di quegli episodi
Che gettano
Un'ombra
Stavolta
Fin dall'inizio
Ve l'ho detto
La fucilazione
Dell'arcivescovo
Avverrà negli ultimissimi giorni
In mezzo al massacro
Generale
Invece
Già quel primo giorno
18 marzo
Si colloca
Un episodio
Che è come dire
Da chi si oppone
Si opponeva
Allora
E si oppone oggi
Al ricordo della comune
Viene additato
Come dire
Come qualcosa
Che getta davvero
Un'ombra
Sulle origini
Della comune
Perché il generale
Leconte
Viene arrestato
Dai suoi stessi soldati
Viene tenuto
Prigioniero
Per qualche ora
Con la folla
Che tumultua fuori
E lo vuole ammazzare
Poi alla fine
I soldati
E la guardia nazionale
Si mettono d'accordo
Portano fuori
Il generale Leconte
Lo mettono al muro
E lo fucilano
I soldati
Gridano
Al generale
Volevi farci sparare
Sul popolo
Adesso
È il tuo turno
Marx
Che da Londra
Segue attentissimamente
Ora per ora
Quello che sta succedendo
Marx
Commenta
Freddamente
Che i governi
Reazionari
Che insegnano
I soldati
A sparare
A fucilare
La gente
E poi
Devono aspettarsi
Che succedano
Su queste cose
Marx
Il generale Leconte
Aveva ordinato
Per quattro volte
All'ottantunesimo
Fanteria
Di far fuoco
Sui civili
Inermi
In Plas Pigal
E al rifiuto
Dei suoi uomini
Li aveva
Ferocemente insultati
Invece di sparare
Sulle donne
Sui bambini
I suoi soldati
Spararono
Su di lui
Le abitudini
Inveterate
Acquisite
Dai soldati
Alla scuola
Dei nemici
Della classe
Operaia
Non è che
Scompaiano
Nel momento
In cui i soldati
Passano al fianco
Degli operai
Una volta
Che hanno imparato
A comportarsi
In un certo modo
Continuano
A farlo
In realtà
I generali
Fucilati
Sono due
Perché c'è
Un altro generale
Molto in viso
Alla guardia nazionale
Il generale
Clement Thomas
Che il governo
Borghese
Aveva nominato
Comandante
Della guardia nazionale
E che i suoi uomini
Non amavano
Il generale Thomas
Si era dimesso
Quel giorno
In borghese
Va a vedere
A Montmartre
Cosa sta succedendo
Lo riconoscono
Lo arrestano
Lo mettono insieme
Al generale Lecomte
Li tirano fuori
Tutti e due
Li mettono al muro
Quello stesso giorno
18 marzo
Thiers
E il governo
Fuggono a Versailles
E i battaglioni
Della guardia nazionale
Eleggono un comitato
Centrale
Che constatata
La fuga del governo
Prende il potere
A Parigi
A nome
Del proletariato
Vi leggo
Due righe
Dal decreto
Dal comunicato
Perché è importante
Come dire
Quando si studia
Un avvenimento storico
Capire il linguaggio
Che usavano
Quelli che c'erano
Dentro
Le idee
Che avevano
In testa
I meccanismi
Mentali
Il comitato
Centrale
Della guardia
Nazionale
Dichiara
I proletari
Della capitale
Di fronte
Alle deficienze
E ai tradimenti
Della classe
Governante
Hanno compreso
Che era giunta
L'ora
Di salvare
La situazione
Prendendo
Nelle proprie
Mani
La direzione
Degli affari
Pubblici
Il comitato
Centrale
Della guardia
Nazionale
Che prende
Il potere
A Parigi
È composto
Da venti
Delegati
Eletti
Dalla truppa
Tutti operai
E a proposito
Del linguaggio
Dell'epoca
Andiamo a vedere
Come la stampa
Francese
Ed europea
Racconta
I suoi lettori
Il fatto
Che venti
Delegati
Operai
Hanno preso
Il potere
A Parigi
Una ventina
Di mascalzoni
Di bassa
Lega
Thiers
Da Versailles
Dichiara
Che sono
Dei comunisti
Che saccheggeranno
Parigi
E che comunque
Sono degli sconosciuti
E non hanno
Nessun diritto
Di governare
Un giornale
Di Parigi
Risponde
Anche i dodici apostoli
Erano degli sconosciuti
Il diario
Di Edmond Goncourt
Ci dà una chiara idea
Dello sguardo
Con cui
I borghesi
Rimasti a Parigi
Guardano
Quello che sta succedendo
La guardia nazionale
Presidia le strade
Goncourt
Si è presi
Dal disgusto
Alla vista
Delle loro facce
Stupide
E abbiette
Alle quali
Il trionfo
E l'ubriachezza
Conferiscono
Un'aria
Raggiante
E dissoluta
E indubbiamente
L'aspetto fisico
Degli operai
Parigini
Specialmente
Dopo quattro mesi
Di assedio
Ma non solo
Doveva essere
Tale
Da scandalizzare
I borghesi
Abbiamo un'altra
Testimonianza
Di un ufficiale
Uno dei rari
Ufficiali
Di carriera
Di origine
Borghese
Che si sono
Schierati
Con la comune
E che finirà
Fucilato
Naturalmente
Fra poche settimane
Questo ufficiale
Borghese
Racconta
In una lettera
Di questi operai
Che hanno preso
Il potere
A Parigi
Costoro
Hanno buoni motivi
Per combattere
Combattono
Perché i loro figli
Siano meno
Gracili
Meno scrofolosi
Più sani
Di loro
Con la presa
Del potere
Da parte
Del comitato centrale
Si accelera
La fuga
Degli ultimi
Borghesi
Rimasti a Parigi
Proprietari
Professionisti
Insegnanti
Nel giro di un mese
Centinaia
Di migliaia
Di persone
Lasciano la città
E la stampa europea
Continua a scrivere
Che appunto
Parigi
E' sprofondata
Nella barbarie
Qualche citazione
A caso
La Repubblica
Rossa
Dominata
Dai ladri
Dai teppisti
E dai demagoghi
Comunismo
Della peggior
Specie
La canaglia
Di Parigi
Al potere
Miscredenti
Senza Dio
Dilettanti
Incapaci
Fuorilegge
Cafoni
Analfabeti
Questa è l'immagine
Che si dà
In realtà
Il comitato centrale
Che ha fatto
Una rivoluzione
Senza che nessuno
Se lo aspettasse
E' estremamente
Incerto
Su cose sono
Le prossime cose
Da fare
E in realtà
Sembra proprio
Che la principale
Preoccupazione
Sia di conservare
Una legalità
Democratica
Di far capire
Che qui le cose
Funzionano
Appunto
Secondo delle regole
Il 26 marzo
A Parigi
Si vota
Per eleggere
Il consiglio
Municipale
Vota circa
Il 50%
Degli aventi diritto
Ma questo
Perché Parigi
Si è svuotata
I quartieri
Borghesi
Sono vuoti
E la maggioranza
Schiacciante
Degli eletti
Al consiglio comunale
Sono ovviamente
Rossi
I pochi eletti
Nei quartieri
Borghesi
Si dimettono
E il consiglio
Municipale
Decide di adottare
Ufficialmente
Il nome di
Comune
Di Parigi
E il 28 marzo
Il comitato centrale
Della guardia nazionale
Cede i pieni poteri
Alla comune
Che decreta
L'adozione
Della bandiera rossa
Tanto per tranquillizzare
Ulteriormente i borghesi
Decreta
L'adozione
Della bandiera rossa
Come bandiera
Del governo
E si fa
Una grande cerimonia
Di insediamento
Della comune
Davanti all'hotel
Deville
Con parata
Della guardia nazionale
Indivisa
Salve di cannone
La folla
Festante
I consiglieri
Comunali
In cilindro
Eredingot
Perché questa volta
Non sono tutti operai
I delegati
Del comitato centrale
Erano tutti operai
Ma adesso
Il consiglio comunale
È pieno di giornalisti
Di avvocati
Di insegnanti
Gli operai
Sono circa un terzo
Nelle foto
Della cerimonia
Di insediamento
Sono lì col cilindro
Si potrebbe
Aver l'impressione
Che fosse una normale
Manifestazione politica
Dei tempi
Dell'impero
Se non fosse
Che noi sappiamo
Che la folla
Canta la marsigliese
E la comune
Comincia a attuare
I suoi primi provvedimenti
Che non hanno niente
Di comunista
Non ci sono
La confisca
Della proprietà privata
La preoccupazione
È aiutare la gente
Che sta crepando di fame
E quindi
Viene cancellato
Il pagamento
Degli affitti
Nove mesi
Di abbuono
Rinnovato
Il blocco
Degli sfratti
Libri
E quaderni
Scolastici
Gratuiti
Poi ci sono anche
Le misure
Idealistiche
Nessun funzionario
Della comune
Potrà avere
Uno stipendio
Superiore
Al salario
Di un operaio
Abolizione
Della pena
Di morte
La folla
Va alla polizia
A prelevare
La ghigliottina
E la brucia
In piazza
In mezzo
Ai festeggiamenti
Eguaglianza
Di tutti gli stranieri
Residenti a Parigi
Chiunque risieda
A Parigi
È uguale agli altri
È cittadino
Può essere eletto
E così via
Le misure più estreme
Sono quelle
Contro la Chiesa
La quale
Come vi dicevo
È odiata
E non fa niente
Per non farsi odiare
Perché dal pulpito
I parroci
Stanno tuonando
Contro quello
Che accade a Parigi
La parola
Rivoluzione
È il grido
Di Satana
E quindi
Decreto della comune
Separazione
Di Stato e Chiesa
Confisca
Dei beni
Ecclesiastici
Eliminazione
Dei crocifissi
Dalle aule
Scolastiche
Vedete come noi
Viviamo ancora sempre
Nella stessa epoca
Sotto certi punti di vista
Le cose su cui
Ci si scontra
Tutti si illudono
Che le cose
Possono andare avanti così
E a dire il vero
Perfino la banca Rothschild
In quei giorni
Concede un prestito
Alla comune
Al governo di Parigi
Perché
Tutto sommato
Non si pensa
Che stia
Per scoppiare
Una guerra civile
Solo qualcuno
Ha capito
Che in realtà
Parigi è sola
E che non c'è
Nessuna speranza
Di tirare avanti
Qualcuno ha capito
Che fin dall'inizio
Fin da quando
Hanno fucilato
I due generali
Questa cosa
È il pretesto
Con cui
Il governo
Rifiuterà
Di negoziare
E di riconoscere
La comune
Nelle discussioni
Che si fanno
Nel consiglio
Della comune
C'è qualcuno
Che dice
Abbiamo ammazzato
I due generali
Non importa
Se loro se lo meritavano
O no
La comune
È foutue
Siamo fregati
Perché a livello
Di immagine
Questa cosa
Non ci verrà mai
Perdonata
E infatti
A Versailles
Il ministro
Favre
Dichiara
I giornali
Non si negozia
Con gli assassini
E se non si negozia
Cosa si fa
Il 21 marzo
Tre giorni
Dopo essere scappato
A Versailles
Thiers
Dichiara
All'assemblea nazionale
Qualunque cosa
Avvenga
Non vogliamo
Attaccare Parigi
Non è né la prima
Nell'ultima menzogna
In quegli stessi giorni
Thiers
Sta reclutando soldati
E soprattutto
Ha fatto un accordo
Con Bismarck
Il quale
Non intende
Coinvolgere
Le truppe tedesche
In questa faccenda
Ma è ben contento
Che i francesi
Sterminino
I rivoluzionari
Di Parigi
Perciò
Bismarck
Sottobanco
Contro le clausole
Del trattato
Di pace
Accetta
Di liberare
In anticipo
I prigionieri
Di guerra
In modo che
I soldati
Dell'esercito
Di Napoleone III
Tornano in patria
A disposizione
Del governo
Repubblicano
Negli stessi giorni
In cui dichiara
Che non ha nessuna
Intenzione
Di attaccare Parigi
Thierre
Scrive a un amico
Sto riorganizzando
L'esercito
E spero
Che in due o tre
Settimane
Avremo soldati
Sufficienti
Per liberare
Parigi
Thierre è stato
Attaccato
Con immensa violenza
Per la durezza
Della repressione
A cui abbiamo
Accennato all'inizio
E su cui adesso
Chiudendo
Torneremo
Cosa ha in mente
Thierre in realtà
È una personalità
Complessa
Thierre
Da un lato
La sensazione
È che si senta
Una specie di Lincoln
Tenete presente
Che la guerra civile
Americana
È finita solo
Da cinque anni
E Lincoln
In America
Ha fatto una guerra civile
Spaventosa
Per
Affermare il principio
Che il governo nazionale
È uno solo
E nessuno
Può ribellarsi
Al governo nazionale
Thierre
Ha certamente
In mente questo
Bisogna
Riaffermare
L'autorità
Dello Stato
Senza
Negoziare
Quando i deputati
Di Parigi
Vanno da Thierre
E gli dicono
Ma
Negoziamo
Avviate un accordo
Con la comune
La risposta di Thierre
È
Parigi
Sarà sottomessa
All'autorità
Dello Stato
Come un
Qualsiasi
Borgo
Di un centinaio
Di abitanti
Questo
È il centralismo
È lo statalismo
Dell'Ottocento
Poi Thierre
Ha un altro obiettivo
Lui è un vecchio monarchico
Ma si è davvero
Convertito alla Repubblica
È convinto
Che il futuro è quello
Ci vuole la Repubblica
E bisogna
Rafforzarla
La Francia profonda
È monarchica
Ma il governo
Repubblicano
Farà vedere
Che è così
Forte
Che nessuno
Oserà più
Rimettere in discussione
La Repubblica
E per far vedere
Che siamo forti
Schiacceremo
Parigi
E poi naturalmente
C'è il fatto che
Parigi
Appunto
È un covo di rossi
La comune
È un governo
Comunista
E noi
Li annienteremo
Il desiderio
Di sterminarli
È evidentemente
Diffusissimo
Il primo aprile
Thierre dichiara
All'Assemblea nazionale
Sto mettendo in piedi
Una delle più belle
Armate
Che la Francia
Abbia mai avuto
La lotta
La lotta sarà dolorosa
Ma breve
L'indomani
2 aprile
I soldati del governo
Che ormai tutti chiamano
I versagliesi
Perché il governo
Sta a Versailles
I versagliesi
Dunque il 2 aprile
Attaccano
E prendono
I primi avamposti
E sentendo il cannone
Il nostro amico
Edmond Goncourt
Scrive nel suo diario
Dio sia lodato
È cominciata
La guerra civile
La guerra civile è cominciata
E qui noi potremmo
Anche finire
E stiamo per finire
Effettivamente
Perché noi
Come dire
Abbiamo promesso
Di parlare
Delle origini
Della guerra civile
Però
Come dire
Se resistete
Ancora 5 minuti
Io
Io vorrei ancora
Raccontare
Qualche cosa di più
Di quello che è successo
In quei giorni
Raccontare che
Il 3 aprile
I parigini
Tentano per la prima volta
Un contrattacco
Tentano di marciare
Su Versailles
Sono sconfitti
Perché la guardia nazionale
È numerosa
Ma è fatta tutta
Di volontari
Di dilettanti
Di fronte
Hanno un esercito
Di professionisti
La guardia nazionale
Viene sconfitta
I due generali
Della comune
Che comandavano
L'attacco
Vengono fatti prigionieri
E lì per la prima volta
Si capisce
Com'è
Che quelli di Versailles
Vogliono fare la guerra
Perché dei due generali
Prigionieri
Al primo
Un ufficiale di cavalleria
Spacca la testa
Sciabolate
E l'altro
Viene messo al muro
Era un operaio
Un fonditore
Duval
La comune
L'aveva nominato generale
Quella mattina stessa
Per comandare l'attacco
Viene messo al muro
E fucilato
E fra i prigionieri
Tutti quelli
Che risultano essere
Ex soldati
Passati
Alla guardia nazionale
Vengono messi al muro
E fucilati
Poi si continua
A combattere
Appunto
Per un mese e mezzo
Fino a quando
Nell'ultima settimana
I soldati arrivano
Al centro di Parigi
Ed è la settimana
Di sangue
E la violenza
Di quella settimana
È tale
Che noi dobbiamo
Ancora aggiungere qualcosa
Per cercare
Di spiegarla
Il punto è
Che di fronte
A Parigi
Operaia
Insorta
Che tutti gli avversari
Accusano di essere
Un covo
Di comunisti
Dall'altra abbiamo
Un esercito
Che ti era messo in piedi
Con i soldati
Dell'imperatore
I soldati dell'imperatore
Che erano soldati
Di mestiere
Perché sotto
Napoleone III
Si sorteggiava
E chi veniva tirato
A sorte
Si faceva sette anni
Di servizio militare
Erano soldati di mestiere
Quasi tutti contadini
Perché nella Francia
Di Napoleone III
Quando veniva sorteggiato
Un operaio
Per fare il soldato
Quasi sempre
La commissione di leva
Lo rimandava a casa
Perché gli operai
Erano gracili
Malconci
Affamati
E malati
E un esercito
Di contadini
Che hanno giurato
Fedeltà all'imperatore
Sono scesi in guerra
Con lui
Hanno subito
I disastri
Della guerra
Contro la Prussia
Sono rimasti
Sei mesi
Prigionieri
In Germania
Adesso li hanno
Rimandati in Francia
E il governo
Gli dice
Non potete ancora
Tornare a casa
C'è ancora
Un lavoro
Da fare
C'è Parigi
In mano
Alla feccia
Ai comunisti
A quelli
Che vogliono
Portarvi via
La vostra terra
E le vostre donne
Dobbiamo domare
La feccia di Parigi
E poi voi
Potrete tornare
Alle vostre case
E quando i soldati
Attaccano
I comunisti
Sparano
Dalle barricate
Gli uomini
Perfino le donne
Sparano
A questo punto
I soldati
Non capiscono più niente
Capiscono solo
Che bisogna
Ammazzarli tutti
Quanta responsabilità
Abbia Thier
In questi eccidi
È una cosa
Che da sempre
Discussa
Lui stesso
A un certo punto
Si è preoccupato
Perché la sera
Del 22
Il secondo giorno
Della settimana
Di sangue
Con le truppe
Già dentro
Parigi
Thier
Aveva emanato
Un proclama
In cui dichiarava
Che la legge
L'ordine
E la civiltà
Trionfavano
E si concludeva
Dicendo
L'espiazione
Sarà
Totale
Più tardi
Thier dirà
Che lui era stato
Frainteso
E che anzi
Aveva dato ordini
Severissimi
Perché la rabbia
Dei soldati
Fosse controllata
Ma l'esercito
Parole di Thier
Interpretò
A suo modo
Il mio proclama
Sull'espiazione
Totale
Gli esempi
Di quel che succede
Potrei andare avanti
Un'ora
Ma andrò avanti
Solo un minuto
23 maggio
Conquistata
Montmartre
49 comunardi
Presi a caso
Comprese donne
E ragazzini
Sono portati
Davanti al muro
Dove erano stati
Fucilati
I due generali
Fatti in ginocchiare
E fucilati
Testimonianze a caso
Di testimoni
Spesso stranieri
Giornalisti
Osservatori
Vidi un plotone
Di soldati
Entrare in una casa
Domandarono
Alla portiera
Se vi fossero
Dei comunisti
Nascosti
Rispose di no
Perquisirono
La casa
E ne trovarono uno
Lo portarono fuori
E lo fucilarono
E poi
Fucilarono
Anche lei
In molti casi
I soldati
Fucilano
I feriti
Negli ospedali
E a volte
Anche i medici
Negli ospedali
Della comune
Negli ultimi combattimenti
A Belleville
Un testimone inglese
Racconta
Di aver visto
Un gruppo
Di donne armate
Che hanno difeso
Una barricata
Che dopo essere
State catturate
Vengono messe al muro
52 donne
Vengono fucilate
Ovviamente
Non tutti
Vengono fucilati
Ci sono anche
Migliaia di prigionieri
Che vengono avviati
Con le mani legate
Verso Versailles
Con la cavalleria
Che li spinge avanti
A sciabolate
E quando qualcuno
Si ferma
O cade
E viene ammazzato
Sul posto
Quando poi
I prigionieri
Arrivano
All'uscita di Parigi
Lì c'è il comandante
Della cavalleria
Il generale
Marchese de Galifè
Eroe di guerra
Che ha comandato
Una disperata
Carica di cavalleria
La battaglia di Sedan
Quando gli passano
Davanti le colonne
Di prigionieri
Il generale de Galifè
Li passa in rassegna
E decide
Chi fucilare
Sceglie quelli
Che hanno i capelli bianchi
Perché vuol dire
Voi eravate già qui
Nel 48
Ne avete già fatta
Un'altra di rivoluzione
Non vi è bastato?
Sceglie quelli
Che hanno l'orologio
Perché vuol dire
Che non sono operai
Sono studenti
Sono borghesi
Sono i capi
Sono i più pericolosi
Ovviamente
Le atrocità
Si scatenano
Anche dall'altra parte
Perché nelle ultime settimane
La comune
Si radicalizza
Di fronte a quello
Che sta succedendo
Nella comune
Vanno al potere
Gli estremisti
I nostalgici
Del terrore
Si creano
Come ai tempi
Di Robespierre
Un comitato
Di salute pubblica
Un tribunale
Rivoluzionario
A capo
Del comitato
Di salute pubblica
C'è un vecchio
Giacobino
De Lecluse
Uno che si è fatto
Sei anni
Di deportazione
All'isola del diavolo
Sotto Napoleone III
È tornato
Tisico
Moribondo
Lui e altri
Dicono chiaramente
Che piuttosto
Che essere sconfitti
Meglio sprofondare
Nel sangue
E nel fuoco
Se saremo sconfitti
Bruceremo Parigi
E Parigi
Brucia davvero
E gli incendi
Su questo
Non ci sono dubbi
Sono scatenati
Per ordine
Della comune
Brucia
Il palazzo imperiale
Le Tuileries
Che infatti
Non ci sono più
Ci sono i giardini
Delle Tuileries
Accanto all'Uvro
Lo sapete
Brucia
L'Hotel Deville
Il cielo di Parigi
È oscurato
Dal fumo
E dalla cenere
A molti testimoni
Vengono in mente
La caduta
Di Babilonia
Nell'Apocalisse
O Sodoma
E Gomorra
O Pompei
Che è di gran moda
Come sapete
Alla fine dell'Ottocento
Non c'è nessun dubbio
Ripeto
Ci sono testimonianze
Chiarissime
Sono incendi
Voluti
Organizzati
Si portano
Le latte di petrolio
Si dà fuoco a tutto
È un mito
Invece
Che però
Si diffonde
Immediatamente
Il mito
Delle rivoluzionarie
Le donne
Che vanno in giro
Con le bottiglie
Di petrolio
Per dar fuoco
A tutto
Le petroleuse
La stampa
Comincia immediatamente
A dire
Che Parigi brucia
Perché le mogli
Degli operai
Queste megere
Queste streghe
Danno fuoco
A tutto
E sono innumerevoli
I casi di donne
O ragazzine
Fucilate in mezzo
Alla strada
Perché andavano in giro
Con un bidone
Di qualcosa
Non ci mettono niente
A metterle al muro
E la comune
Continua anche lei
A fucilare
Finora non aveva
Fucilato gli ostaggi
Adesso invece
Sì
Il 24 maggio
Come vi dicevo
Viene fucilato
L'arcivescovo
Di Parigi
E Raul Rigaud
Che lo aveva fatto
Arrestare
Non è lì
In quel momento
Perché sta combattendo
Sulle barricate
Al quartier latino
In divisa
Della guardia nazionale
E quello stesso giorno
Lo stesso giorno
In cui viene fucilato
L'arcivescovo
Anche Raul Rigaud
Che lo aveva fatto
Arrestare
Viene catturato
Dal nemico
Riconosciuto
E gli mettono
Una palla in testa
E si continua
Da entrambe le parti
Il 25 maggio
Un reparto
Della guardia nazionale
Senza ordini
Fucila
Tutti i frati
Domenicani
Di un convento
E i loro dipendenti
Il 26
La guardia nazionale
Fucila
E finisce
A colpi
Di baionetta
Altri 51 ostaggi
11 fra preti
E frati
Gli altri poliziotti
Siamo ormai
Agli ultimi giorni
I soldati
Sono arrivati
Ai quartieri operai
Il 27 maggio
Il capo
Del comitato
Di salute pubblica
Dele Cluse
Lascia una lettera
Per la sorella
Non voglio
Ne posso
Servire da vittima
E da zimbello
Alla reazione
Vittoriosa
Perdonami
Se me ne vado
Prima di te
Che mi hai sacrificato
La vita
Ma non ho il coraggio
Di subire
Un'altra sconfitta
Poi indossa
La sciarpa
Di presidente
Del comitato
Di salute pubblica
Va a una barricata
Sale in piedi
Sulla barricata
E si fa uccidere
Il 28 maggio
I combattimenti
Sono finiti
Parigi è conquistata
Le fucilazioni
Però non finiscono
I soldati perquisiscono
Controllano
Tutti gli uomini
In borghese
Vengono arrestati
Si guarda
Hai le mani sporche
Di polvere da sparo
Al muro
Hai i lividi
Sulla spalla
Perché quando spari
Il moschetto
E lo spari
Per un po' di volte
Ti rimane il livido
Al muro
Per diversi giorni
Si fucila
Al cimitero di Montparnasse
Al parco Monceau
Nei giardini
Del Luxembourg
Oggi noi andiamo a Parigi
Visitiamo questi posti
E' ben difficile
Immaginare che
150 anni fa
Lì si fucilava
In massa la gente
Poi i cadaveri
Vengono sepolti
In fosse comuni
O bruciati
Fuori città
Molti cercano
Di scappare
Ma fuori da Parigi
Ci sono i tedeschi
Le truppe tedesche
Sono ancora lì
Che rinserrano
La città
Nel loro cerchio
E tuttavia
Engels
Testimonia
Che i soldati tedeschi
Quando possono
Lasciano passare
I fuggiaschi
E anche gli ufficiali
Prussiani
Chiudono un occhio
Perché la realtà
E' che l'orrore
Di questa repressione
Sta scandalizzando
Il mondo
Che come abbiamo ben visto
Non aveva la minima
Simpatia
Per la comune
E che tuttavia
Rimane scioccato
Da quello che sta succedendo
Perfino il Times
Di Londra
Aggrotta la fronte
E scrive
Che la sete di sangue
Dei soldati di Versailles
Pare perfino
Superiore
A quella dei comunisti
E che se sotto
Il regime dei rossi
Si sono commessi
Crimini abominevoli
Quello che sta succedendo
Fa ancora più orrore
Processi
Condanni a morte
Fucilazioni
Contenano fino a fine anno
Poi per qualche anno
Ancora deportazioni
Oltre 4.000 deportati
Alla Cayenna
E poi il clima cambia
Io qui chiudo
Perché è già tardissimo
Ma ci pensavo proprio oggi
Che sarebbe affascinante
Studiare come
E perché
E in quanto tempo
Dopo tragedie
Come questa
Si arriva a una
Riconciliazione vera
Per cui c'è l'amnistia
La gente torna
Ecco in questo caso
Ci vuole una decina d'anni
L'amnistia è proclamata
Nel 1880
I deportati
Cominciano a tornare
Due mesi prima
Si è tenuto
Sfidando il divieto
Il primo pellegrinaggio
Al cimitero
Del Perlachese
Il primo pellegrinaggio
Al muro
Dei fucilati
25.000 persone
Con un fiore rosso
All'occhiello
Da allora
Ogni primo maggio
Si è ripetuto
Il pellegrinaggio
Al muro
Dei fucilati
E
Come capite
È difficilissimo
Finire il racconto
Di una storia
Così divisiva
Perciò lo farò
Non con parole mie
Ma con le parole
Di uno che era lì
E che non si era schierato
Un pittore
Renoir
Uno dei grandi impressionisti
Avete presente
Renoir era lì
Era a Parigi
E mentre dipingeva
Sulle rive della Senna
I comunardi
Lo avevano scambiato
Per una spia
E se l'era vista brutta
Finché non era arrivato
Di tutti quelli
Che potevano arrivare
Raul Rigaud
Che lo conosceva
Che l'ha abbracciato
E che ha detto
Lasciatelo andare
Renoir
Dirà
Dei comunardi
Erano folli
Ma avevano in sé
Quella fiammella
Che non si estingue
Grazie
Applausi
Grazie a tutti
Via
E per chi vuole
Per chi vuole
Sono ancora qui
Per firmare dei libri
E per tutti gli altri
All'anno prossimo
Arrivederci
Applausi
Grazie